[Musique]
chaque journaliste a toujours été
engagée chaque éditorialistes ont
toujours été engagée lorsque vous
lorsque vous lisez libération vous
n'avez pas la même ligne éditoriale que
le figaro le sujet se pose soyons clair
aujourd'hui principalement parce que il
y a un potentiel mans 1-1
d'éditorialistes journaliste de renom
qui s'interrogent pour les élections
présidentielles je crois que c'est
principalement la le sujet parce que
parlons également de choses concrètes
aujourd'hui le csa est très regardant
par le biais de les invectives de
stéphane ces journées qui travaille au
secrétariat général de l'élysée à
regarder ce que fait ces news du matin
au soir
j'ai envie de dire regardons un peu ce
que font également d'autres chaînes
meanstream je pense à lci vous avez un
jean michel aphatie qui défend macron du
matin au soir vous allez sur bfm vous
avez un christophe barbier qui incarne
finalement la macro ni donc non pour moi
il ne faut pas comptabiliser le temps de
parole des éditorialistes dans le cas
d'une élection présidentielle
tout simplement parce qu'ils ne sont pas
candidats dans un parti politique peut
simplement parce que la loi ne le permet
pas et que c'est encore une fois cette
liberté d'expression qu'il ya toujours
eu la presse d'opinion effectivement
lire libération dans sa trace et pas
lire le figaro lire le figaro c'est pas
lire valeurs actuelles et tout ça on est
bien d'accord pour autant monsieur
zemmour qui manie la chèvre et chou qui
effectivement dit qu'ils seraient
peut-être peut-être éventuellement
candidat à la présidentielle là en
l'occurrence lui il faut qu'il clarifie
le jeu parce que de fait si il se
présente à la présidentielle il peut
plus être un éditorialiste comme esau un
sondage récent et ça je le dis soit des
français très intéressant parce que les
français sont pour un départ il ya un
vrai problème de fond c'est les
émissions politiques à la télé c'était
devenu une catastrophe
les français ont besoin en tant que
téléspectateur d'aborder les points de
vue et je suis heureux que sur arte
france on peut avoir une liberté de
découpe et de l'un et de l'autre
eh bien ça aussi je crois que c'est à
discuter et moi voyez vous j'aime les
types d'émissions que quelqu'un
connaissait bien lier sur notre chaîne
c'était l'émission de taddeï qui
s'appelle ce soir ou jamais ça c'était
des émissions intéressant parce que là
il y avait du départ de moi on pouvait
développer ces sites et voilà je vous
conte débattre du fond
[Musique]
le pouvoir est aujourd'hui dans la main
des médias
c'est une réalité et aucun politique
gilles bien aucun politique ne peut
espérer obtenir le graal 2 par exemple
de l'élection présidentielle est
d'arriver l'elysée en se mettant les
médias doux et on ne peut pas se
plaindre d'un côté que les français se
désintéressent de la politique avec une
offre aussi fourni aussi diverses aussi
variés parce qu'il ya des lignes
éditoriales différentes qu'ils puissent
s'exprimer sur les écrans donc je pense
que c'est plutôt pour moi plutôt
pertinent et puis après est ce que ces
grands médias sont dans les mains de
certains financiers j'ai envie de vous
dire ils sont soit dans les mains de
certains financiers vous soit dans le
temps et à aigle lorsque vous regardez
avec avec on dirait jeu avec avec
gourmandise la ligne éditoriale de
france inter ou de france info vous vous
rendrez compte quand même que grâce à
votre redevance télévisuelle
vous avez quand même une ligne
éditoriale qui est extrêmement marqué et
là pour le coup on pourra pas dire du
coup que france inter est un
contre-pouvoir mais bel et bien le bras
armé par exemple du pouvoir en place
donc pour moi c'est important qu'il y
ait d'autres médias qui soit privée mais
j'ai envie de vous dire tant mieux pour
notre démocratie qu'il y ait des
contre-pouvoirs médiatique fois qu'il
est intéressant pour nous et tous les
téléspectateurs des pertes et france
d'être lucide comme les et rené char la
lucidité c'est la plaie sur la plus
rapprochée du soleil c'est la phrase
préférée françois mitterrand soit dit au
passage et où le littéraire que je suis
ne peut pas s'empêcher de dire que le
niveau pesme épaisse mais baisse au
niveau du discours politique d'une
manière incroyable et d'ailleurs pas
forcément dans mon coeur a été peut-être
le plus lucide de ces 30 dernières
années en dix ans en dix ans les
politiques parlent une langue morte
c'était l'ancien premier ministre manuel
valls effectivement pourquoi les gens
d'ailleurs je vous le dire je le dis
très sincèrement il est parfois plus
intéressant d'écouter renée doctoriales
is passionnant et passionné d'écouter un
sociologue un homme de comme un psycho
sociologue d'écouté des gens comme nous
les experts parfois où qu'on soit
d'ailleurs les gens ne se trompe pas
dans les dernières études
ces gens là que j'ai envie d'écouter et
absolument pas un politique avec sa
longue
à ces éléments de langage que c'est
conseillant comme lors des tirs regardez
le scandale à chaque fois que le
gouvernement a quelque chose à dire il
balance toute l'armée sur toutes les
chaînes mainstream et pour dire la même
chose parce qu'il faut des contraintes
et il faut simplement faire en sorte de
faire appliquer la loi qui existe à
l'ensemble des citoyens quels qu'ils
soient journalistes citoyens anonymes ou
hommes politiques
tout simplement on applique la loi
strictement la loi et les sanctions sont
appliquées sur quels critères allons
nous nourrir un bureau dédié
six cas si ce n'est celui de la loi donc
pas besoin de monter un comité ad-hoc
si un journaliste qui a dit une bêtise
il est réprimandé fonctionner basta on
s'en arrête là je crois que cette
volonté de vouloir avoir une mainmise
sur les contenus éditoriaux présage soit
d'un gouvernement aux tendances des
tortues pas sûr en tout cas extrêmement
fébrile quant à son avenir
il ya un certain nouveau directeur de la
politique les service politique de
france 2 ça monsieur qui s'appelle
comment un certain cyril katia ni
pourquoi a été placé là ça des
meilleures années du président de la
république
alors si l institution tu va nommer
quelqu'un voudrait voir pourquoi il
nomme à des postes très importants des
gens qui eux même quelque part on
déroule et joue ça tout est politique
la france est un pays qui gouvernait
d'une manière depuis longtemps avec un
passé et un inconscient royalistes et
maintenant on fait ce qu'il peut il veut
être élu c'est tout et marine le pen est
sa meilleure adversaire faut savoir
c'est marine le pen la chance d emmanuel
macron pas d'institution nouvelle tout
est dans la loi
tout est dans la loi